♪ Hark the herald angels sing ♪
♪ Glory to the newborn King ♪
♪ Tidings of comfort and joy ♪
♪ Comfort and ♪
♪ Joy to the world, the Lord has come ♪
♪ Dashing through the snow ♪
♪ In a one-horse open sleigh ♪
♪ Over the fields we go ♪
♪ Laughing all the way, ha ha ha ♪
(prisoners chatter)
(prisoners cheer)
♪ Hmm ♪
♪ Joy to the world, the world ♪
♪ The Lord is come, is come ♪
♪ Let Earth receive her King ♪
♪ Her King, her King ♪
♪ Let every heart prepare Him room ♪
♪ And heaven and nature
sing, nature sing ♪
♪ And heaven and heaven and nature sing ♪
(prisoners applaud and cheer)
♪ Amazing grace ♪
♪ How sweet, sweet the sound ♪
♪ Sound ♪
♪ That saved a wretch like me, like me ♪
♪ I once was lost, lost ♪
♪ But now I'm found, found ♪
♪ Was blind but now I see ♪
- Psst, hey.
Thank you, Merry Christmas.
- [Woman] Shh.
- Joseph, I'm not feeling very well.
I'm really tired and I have a pain.
I think it's time for the baby to be born.
- Please, Mary, lie down
here on this nice bed I made
in the straw.
- Oh, yeah.
Lay down, Mary.
(prisoners cheer)
- Jesus fucking Christ.
- All right, ladies.
Knock it off, knock it off.
Joseph, you were saying?
- That should've been us up there.
- I know.
- Lie down, Mary.
It won't be long now.
(light piano music)
♪ I saw the light ♪
♪ No more in darkness, no more at night ♪
♪ Now I'm so happy, no sorrow in sight ♪
♪ Praise the Lord, I saw the light ♪
(light piano music)
(prisoners snicker)
♪ Just like the blind
man, I wandered alone ♪
♪ Worries and fears I claimed for my own ♪
♪ Then like the blind man ♪
♪ That God gave back his sight ♪
♪ Praise the Lord, I saw the light ♪
- [Prisoner] Yeah.
♪ I saw the light, I saw the light ♪
- You should be in the center,
you should be in the center.
♪ No more in darkness, no more at night ♪
♪ Now I'm so happy, no sorrow in sight ♪
♪ Praise the Lord, I saw the light ♪
♪ Praise the Lord ♪
♪ I saw the light ♪